JOSH TREICHEL: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for joining.
Welcome to today's presentation.
We're going to talk about
building a hybrid data pipeline
with Kafka and Confluent.
My name is Josh Treichel.
I lead partner solutions
engineering at Confluent.
I'm excited today to be
joined by Sarthak from GCP.
Both Sarthak and GCP have
been great partners to us
over the years.
So Sarthak, please introduce
yourself and take it away.
SARTHAK GANGOPADHYAY:
Awesome, thanks, Josh.
Thanks, everyone, for joining.
As Josh mentioned,
my name is Sarthak.
I'm a partner engineer
for Google, for GCP,
for North America.
And I work pretty
closely with Josh
on designing these architectures
and solving these customer
problems.
First, we're going to
spend a few minutes
on this studying the agenda.
We are going to first talk
about what is the exact problem
statement which we are trying
to solve today, what is Apache
Kafka and what is Confluent.
We are hoping everyone
in this audience
is familiar with
Kafka, but this is just
to have an introduction with it.
We are going to talk about how
to build hybrid data pipelines
using Kafka and Confluent.
And finally, we are going to
look at some of the common use
cases, common design patterns
which our customers have
implemented in production and
are having great success when
doing this hybrid data pipeline.
One business problem which we
also see in our personal lives,
which probably all
of you can relate to,
is the total volume of data
which is getting produced
and consumed every day, both
at an individual level as well
as an enterprise level,
is increasing tenfold.
And also, the window
of opportunity
when you can actually
take that data
and take business insights,
helpful business insights,
is reducing drastically.
One example of that is
happening all around us
with COVID, and coronavirus,
and all the aftermath of that
from economic, political, and
business competitive landscape,
which is changing
every day, every week.
Now, with a tremendous
increase in the volume of data,
from a business
standpoint, if you
have to make a decision on how
to best adjust your business,
both at a larger
organization level as well
as a lot of smaller
tactical project
level and everyday
decisions level,
your window of
opportunity is really low.
It's probably a few
hours or a few days
where you have to
actually process the data
and understand how best to
take actions based on the data.
If you look at over
the last decade or so,
how this industry
has kind of evolved,
it is primarily on batch data.
When a large volume of data
gets collected over the day,
only a small amount of data
gets used during the day.
Other data is kind of uploaded
for FTP or other technologies,
for a nightly job
or a weekly job.
And then it is kind
of processed offline.
Often, then what happens is
because of the batch nature
of the analytics data,
the business decisions,
what you will take, kind
of lags by a huge margin.
We have seen, for example, the
fraud detection risk scenarios.
We have seen, many times,
it takes weeks, even months,
for them to determine whether a
particular transaction or a set
of transactions were fraud or
whether a set of transactions
have correlation to
determine whether it
was a fraudulent
transaction or not.
In today's world, more
and more organizations
are trying to take
these decisions
in more near real time.
So they are trying to
capture opportunities
from things like market trend
analysis or user behavior
tracking.
When a user for retail
is coming on your website
and on your mobile
apps, you are too
going to try to
predict their behavior,
provide more relevant
situations and recommendations
or so on and so forth,
with as near real-time as
possible and not
based on the user data
a week back or two months back.
And similarly, even in
case of reduction of risk,
other than fraud detection
from bad actor identification
and a whole bunch of other
use cases, more and more
enterprises needs to make these
decisions in near real time.
So with that challenge
in mind, a lot of times,
the customers come to cloud and
to GCP and try to leverage some
of the analytics capabilities
and AI capabilities
and the surveillance ability,
which GCP is awesome at,
and try to see how can they
leverage those Google to get
abilities to actually
solve those problems
in near real time.
But when they look at
their on-prem system,
one thing which kind of stands
in a lot of times is they
might be heavily
invested in Kafka.
Hopefully, all of you or many
of you are familiar with Kafka.
Kafka is a messaging platform.
It is for pub/sub.
It is a pub/sub.
It's extremely scalable
messaging platform.
The whole idea of messaging
and publish-subscribe
is nothing new.
This has been there from the
good old days of JMS to MQ.
We have seen many incarnations.
Coming out of LinkedIn,
I think in 2011,
coming out of a few
smart software engineers
over at LinkedIn, what Kafka
did, it kind of reinvented
the whole world of
publish/subscribe
and created the system which is
infinitely scalable, extremely
fault-tolerant, which can
scale across multiple servers,
multiple data centers,
multiple geographies.
And it had this way to store
all the data infinitely
in the form of logs.
So it kind of created this
brand new architecture
on how pub/sub
should work and which
landed extremely well
as the volume of data
kept increasing on-prem.
So a lot of enterprises
have actually
standardized over
the last decade or so
under Kafka, especially
using that with Apache.
It has kind of
become the backbone
of how all the discrete systems
are kind of coming together
in the enterprise data center.
So what we thought we'll
try to talk about today is,
how can you leverage your
existing investment in Kafka
and try to use that to do
this near real-time use cases
on GCP.
So this is exactly
what hybrid streaming
is trying to solve,
that using GCP
plus Confluent and the
Confluent cloud specifically,
which we are going to
talk about a little later,
how can you actually move this
data from your on-prem systems,
from your existing Kafka,
without changing anything
or minimally anything,
and move the data to GCP
and start leveraging the
world class serverless, NoOps,
extremely scalable
and extremely powerful
analytics platform, which
Google offers across products
like BigQuery, to Dataflow,
to Looker and everything else.
I would hand over to Josh, who
is going to kind of walk you
through about what is
Apache Kafka, and what
is a distributed event
streaming platform,
and how does the whole
thing kind of fits
into this vision of cloud.
So with that, over to you, Josh.
JOSH TREICHEL: Thanks, Sarthak.
I think Sarthak did a
really good job describing
the need for real-time
data, giving some background
about Kafka.
And I think--
I'm expecting that many of you
have at least heard or know
about Kafka at a high level.
I'd like to just take a little
bit of time to talk about some
of the key features of
Kafka that we think really
differentiate it and make
it a streaming platform,
rather than just
pub/sub messaging.
Kafka is most widely known as
kind of the de facto pub/sub
messaging platform.
It is highly distributed and
has a ton of different use
cases throughout organizations.
What people don't know is
that-- or might not know
is that Kafka also stores data.
So similar to HDF,
HDFS, Kafka stores data
replicated in a durable way.
And you can store as
much data as you want.
So you can store
an infinite amount
of data on a Kafka cluster.
Kafka also allows
you to process data.
So via Kafka streams,
KSQL, or even
single message transformations
in the Kafka Connect framework,
you can interact with
the data in real time
as it's moving through.
On that last slide, I mentioned
Kafka was an event streaming
platform.
I think a lot of people aren't
familiar with the term event
streaming or
probably think like,
why did you create a new term?
We already have kind of existing
terms for data infrastructure.
And we think that with
this new age of data
and how businesses are starting
to build their business
around streaming in real
time, that it really-- it
does matter.
And there is really
this new paradigm shift
towards real-time
event streaming.
And so we created
this new phrase.
And this, it really has
four requirements to it.
So it's built for real time.
It's scalable to
all types of data.
It's persistent and durable,
and it's capable of enrichment.
So you can interact
with the data
as it's moving through
the system in real time.
And there are other
existing data infrastructure
tools out there that
provide a lot of these,
but they don't really
provide all of them.
So you could put together a
number of different systems,
or you could use Apache
Kafka and Confluent
and get the best of breed
event streaming platform.
Some of the key pieces
of events streaming
and specifically for this
hybrid streaming data
pipelining we're
talking about is
being able to connect
systems together.
And in Kafka, the
way you connect
systems is via, aptly named,
the Kafka Connect framework.
Kafka Connect
provides a framework
to easily build connectors.
The ecosystem is built over
100 different connectors
to different systems.
So I can pull data from
pretty much anywhere,
and I can push data to
pretty much anywhere.
And while that
data is in Kafka, I
can interact with it via
something called Kafka Streams.
Kafka Streams is a Java
library to do stream processing
within the Kafka ecosystem.
On top of Kafka Streams,
we've built KSQL.
KSQL is a SQL syntax
that's an abstraction
layer on top of Kafka Streams.
So for non-developers,
you're able to interact
with these streams
of data in real time.
So with Kafka Connect
and Kafka Streams,
we're able to really
simplify data architecture.
So instead of having tens
or hundreds of systems
that need to talk to tens
or hundreds of systems,
we can move data through Kafka.
We can interact with that
data with Kafka Streams.
We can transform it.
We can merge streams.
And then we can
push those streams
to the systems you really want,
like BigQuery, get pulled--
pull the data from to
Dataflow, push it to GCS.
Now let's think about this more
from a customer's perspective.
So what would this look
like in the real world?
If we look on the left, we
have a very simplified view
of some data infrastructure.
We have a bunch of applications.
They look like
microservices applications
that are communicating via a
Kafka in an event-driven way.
Some of those applications
are directly communicating
with some data sources.
We also have data lakes
and other databases
that are connecting to Kafka,
pushing and pulling data,
maybe creating
materialized views in Kafka
for those applications to read.
And that's on-prem or in
some other cloud, right?
And then we have where
people want to go, right?
Like, the world's moving
towards the cloud.
GCP has world-class analytics.
So we want to, as a
customer, take part
in the streaming analytics.
So I'm going to let
Sarthak talk about how we
can connect these two worlds.
SARTHAK GANGOPADHYAY:
Thanks, Josh.
When we talk a lot of time
our enterprise customers,
oftentimes, their
journey wants to-- they
want to start with Google's
world-class analytics.
Their desire might be to
start with GCP to use BigQuery
because you can process
a massive amount of data
much faster, because you
might want to use BigSheets
to connect the data into
Google Sheets and process
in a more business-friendly way.
Or we might do also
visualizations using
Looker and so on and so forth.
Now, what you see on
the right hand side,
this is a pretty
representative architecture
of what that data pipeline
on GCP might look like.
First on the left,
you have PubSub,
which is Google's own version
of pub/sub messaging platform.
This is serverless,
extremely fault-tolerant,
extremely geo-distributed.
Google manage PubSub, which is
very heavily used at Google.
And a lot of customers use
it, and this is typically
what their starting point is.
So they would dump the
data in, and then the data
can get picked up by another
subscription pub/sub topic.
And then it flows
through Dataflow
where there is a processing.
Store the data in
BigQuery, which
is Google's extremely scalable,
NoOps data warehousing tool.
And then finally, they
might do some visualizations
using Data Studio on BigQuery.
On the other hand,
you might also
want to take the same data,
process it through Dataflow,
and then store it in
GCS, and store it using--
in file form, as like Avro,
or Parquet, or whatnot.
Keep in mind, this is a very
representative architecture.
There can be a
lot of variations,
from, instead of data landing
in PubSub, it can land in GCS.
Or instead of just
doing visualizations,
you wait on the trigger
actions using cloud functions
based on the data in BigQuery.
Or you might want
to use AIML, use
BQML for that matter, BigQuery
ML or the ML engine in Google.
Now, as Josh mentioned
that this is always
kind of the desired state.
This is the high
level data pipeline
which you want to go towards.
But in reality, it's virtualized
on the left and especially
if you have invested in Kafka.
So what we are trying to see is
how can you actually leverage
those existing
Kafka infrastructure
in pushing the data to PubSub.
So the way customers
typically do
it today is, PubSub has an
SDK, PubSub has REST APIs.
Using those, they can
actually push the data
from the different applications
and the data stores
and mainframes and
whatnot to PubSub.
And then PubSub, it can start
all these data pipelines.
Though this works, the
challenge with this is,
depending on how complex
the on-prem ecosystem is,
you might need to have--
include that SDK into so
many different applications
and deploy it in production.
And that itself can be
a daunting and a pretty
complicated project,
especially if you
have technologies as
old as mainframe AS/400,
so on and so forth.
So what we started to look at
is if an enterprise have already
invested in Kafka, how
can they actually leverage
that to make that generality
better wherever possible?
So Confluent Cloud, which is
available as a first party
service at GCP-- it is available
directly through Marketplace,
with direct integration
of billings and support
and integrated into
IM, networking,
all that kind of stuff--
they have this
awesome capability
called Confluent Replicator.
So if you are using
Kafka, you can then
leverage that Replicator
capability feature
from Confluent on top of that
and replicate the data pretty
easily from on-prem to GCP.
Now, all your existing
systems are already
pushing data to Kafka, so you
hardly have to do anything.
And then the data, once it
comes to GCP, then the same data
pipeline which we talked about
earlier can be triggered on.
And then the data can go into
all these different paths,
from visualization to cloud
functions, to Data Studio,
and so on and so forth.
I'm going to hand
it over to Josh
now, who is our Kafka and
Confluent expert, to walk you
through what
exactly is Confluent
Cloud, and Replicator, and KSQL,
and all these cool technologies
that you see on the screen.
Josh, over to you.
JOSH TREICHEL: Cool.
I think Sarthak did
a pretty good job
of describing Confluent Cloud
and its tight integration
to GCP.
The idea here is really that
for existing Kafka users,
we're trying to simplify
and ease their adoption
journey to the cloud.
And so as Sarthak
mentioned, there's
a bunch of different
ways you can do this.
There's a number of--
you could go point to
point from a database
directly to BigQuery.
But we think that
for Kafka users,
since Kafka is oftentimes
kind of the way
that those systems connect,
that tapping into that existing
Kafka infrastructure,
getting that-- creating
that persistent bridge, that
real-time bridge to the cloud,
and then being able to integrate
directly to GCP first party
services, and start building
applications with the data
from on-prem in the cloud
is really compelling.
And so Confluent Cloud,
as Sarthak mentioned,
is a fully managed service.
And so this makes the
journey a bit easier, right?
So you're not having
to manage Kafka on-prem
and then manage
Kafka in the cloud.
We take that burden
away from you.
I wanted to talk a little
bit about the two components
on that last slide, Confluent
Cloud and Replicator.
So Confluent Replicator,
on that slide,
it looked like it was
actually kind of part
of both sides of that, right?
So it was part on-prem
and part in the cloud.
It's actually a part of
the Connect framework
or uses the Connect
framework and is a connector.
It's a complicated connector
that has a bunch of cool stuff
that makes it super resilient.
But it's a connector that either
runs on the origin cluster
or at the destination.
So it's either pulling
data across the network
or it's pushing data
across the network.
Typically, we have
it pull data, but you
can run it in either pattern.
And so this Confluent
Replicator allows
us a really nice clean story
to tap into existing Kafka
infrastructure without really
having to touch anything.
So we don't have to go
touch those databases.
We're only hooking into the
existing Kafka installation
on-prem.
And Confluent Cloud,
as Sarthak mentioned,
it's a fully managed service.
If you've ever
managed Kafka before,
you know it can be challenging.
So it's a distributed
system of Kafka brokers.
It's a distributed
system of ZooKeepers.
Kafka Connect is a
distributed system.
And so there's a
lot of complexity
here that we hide from you.
So you don't know how
many brokers there are.
You don't know about ZooKeeper.
When you're running the Connect
framework, this is from a UI
where you just point and click.
So we really-- we think
that this is a whole new way
to run Kafka, kind of
a cloud native Kafka,
that's super compelling.
And it's not just Kafka
that we're running.
We're running Schema Registry.
We're running KSQL.
As I mentioned, we're
running connectors for you.
So if you want to
connect to BigQuery,
you don't have to figure out how
much data you're moving there.
You just go to the
UI, say you want
to connect this topic to
BigQuery, and it starts moving.
And then we allow you
to store as much data
you want on that Kafka
cluster as you need.
So you can store an infinite
amount of data in those topics.
So adding these two features,
if we take a step down
from the more
architecture slide,
if we think about
existing customers
that have on-premise Kafka
infrastructure, whether it's
open source Apache Kafka,
Confluent Enterprise,
they can use
Confluent Replicator.
They can run it on-prem.
They can run it in GCP.
And now they can create this
real-time stream of data
to Confluent Cloud, once the
data is in Confluent Cloud,
take advantage of those
fully managed connectors
and just start pumping
data into the services
that they're most interested in.
They can also have applications
that start directly integrating
with Confluent Cloud.
So building microservices
in an event-driven way
and using Kafka as the
mechanism to do that
is a super common pattern.
So now you can have
Confluent Cloud there
as your event-driven
microservices Kafka.
Let's talk about a
couple use cases here.
To start, just wanted
to talk about the fact
that this is a super kind of
simple, horizontal use case
that can be used
practically for anything.
As Sarthak mentioned
earlier, any use case where
you need real-time data
that doesn't live on GCP,
this is pretty well suited for.
We're taking advantage of the
fact that something like--
it's something like 70%,
75% of Fortune 500 companies
already run Kafka.
So the assumption
here is that that
can be a vast source of
data that we can easily
tap into and start creating
this real-time data pipeline.
Once we have this flow
of real-time data,
we can start building
solutions with it, right?
So if the flow is
from a mainframe,
and you have financial
data, now you
can start building some
fraud analytics on that.
If you're a telecom, you
probably want to think about,
do I have anomalous
activity at my antennas?
That might be something
you're looking at.
But effectively, the
pattern we're talking about
is you're building the
data infrastructure
to get data to GCP.
And then you, the customer,
can build the business solution
that you want to build.
One really cool pattern
that we see a lot is
using this for multi cloud.
A lot of customers
have already--
they live in one
cloud, but they started
to think like, we need to find
the best of breed technologies
across the clouds and use that.
And in the data analytics
world, that's GCP.
So a lot of customers want
to move to GCP for BigQuery,
but the data they want to use in
BigQuery might not live there.
So if the data--
if that's a Kafka user, we can
use that exact same pattern,
right?
Hook up Replicator,
Confluent Cloud, and GCP,
and just start feeding BigQuery.
So your system of record may
live in a different cloud,
but you can actually
use that data
in pretty much near real
time in GCP, in BigQuery.
We actually have customers
that are kind of doing this.
So Unity Technologies,
who GCP and Confluent
have done a joint webinar
with, moved from another cloud
to GCP by building this bridge.
And they moved to
GCP because they
wanted Dataflow and BigQuery.
And they were a Kafka
customer, so this
is the pattern they used.
So Sarthak, maybe
you can just walk us
through how customers might
use this for AI and ML.
SARTHAK GANGOPADHYAY:
Yeah, no, thank you, Josh.
So this particular architecture
diagram which you are seeing,
this is actually a
customer implementation
for a customer in
the banking space
who wanted to handle a
better fraud detection, more
near real time fraud detection,
using GCP's capabilities.
But they had tremendous
data gravity on-prem
because they had a lot of
data in mainframes, in Hadoop,
in Oracle, Teradata, et
cetera, lying on-prem.
Plus, they had a whole bunch
of data from different stores,
to mobile devices, to web,
which is constantly coming in.
And all the systems are set
up to receive that data.
Thankfully, they
were already using
Kafka to communicate across
all these disparate systems
as a message broker on-prem.
And what we did was we
deployed Confluent Cloud
and used Confluent
Replicator, like what
we have been talking about, to
move some of the data to GCP.
Now, as a first step,
what they're doing
is they're actually
taking the full data which
is something every day.
Rather, in near real-time,
as more data is coming in,
they're actually flowing
it through Dataflow
for doing some processing,
storing the full data source
in a stream in BigQuery.
Because in BigQuery now, you
can do a lot faster analysis
across those terabytes
or petabytes of data
than what you could have
on-prem, especially across all
those discrete systems.
And then they're
doing visualizations
of the data using Looker.
But probably, more interesting
is they are actually doing--
in the Confluent Cloud,
they're actually sorting out
some specific data streams.
And those data streams, they
are training some fraud models,
and they're actually
passing it to those fraud--
they're deploying
those fraud models.
And then they're
sending those data
to run those fraud
models to determine
what of those transactions
have any fraudulent behavior
in them.
And then finally,
they're using--
actually sending the
data to a Kafka topic
on running on Confluent Cloud,
so that they can then send back
their feedback downstream
to their on-prem system,
so that based on the
transaction being determined
to be fraudulent or not, they
can actually take actions
on the systems on prem.
I just want to take a second,
and hopefully, you guys
will appreciate, and
understand, and relate
that though this particular
case is for a fraud detection
application, but a very
similar pattern can be applied
to almost every other use
case, from consumer behavior
analysis, to market
trend analysis,
to every other business
scenario which you
can think of, if it satisfy
the criteria of like, hey,
you have--
you're already invested
in Kafka on prem,
and you want to start leveraging
the GCP services like AIML,
or visualizations, or BigQuery,
those things immediately,
without having to
move all the data.
Or you don't want
to wait for you
to move all the data to cloud.
So this kind of sums
up the core messaging
with how can a
hybrid data pipeline
can solve those
business problems.
So thank you very much
for attending our session.
I want to hand it over to
Josh, who has a call to action
for all of you.
So Josh, please take it away.
JOSH TREICHEL: Thanks.
Yeah, I think what
I would love is,
if this sounds
interesting to you,
please check out
Confluent Cloud.
You can spin up a Kafka
cluster in about 10 seconds.
And Confluent covers
the first $200
for the first three
months for everybody,
so it's effectively free to try.
Check it out.
Play around with some KSQL,
and hopefully, you'll love it.
Thanks for joining.